foreign
Paul is up next in NYC Paul welcome to
the show
hey guys thank you so much for taking my
call I'm actually a first time caller
and a long time listener I love it well
how can we help
all right so
um basically right now I'm looking into
um basically making a timeline of when I
can move out of my parents house I mean
I'm not quite there yet but I'm
basically just making my uh early uh
steps in advance okay how old are you
31 okay so what's the plan looking like
so far
so I mean 2022 Was a Very Good Year for
me financially I actually was just going
through my uh my finance spreadsheets
and I actually finished out the year
with 81 000. that was my total year-end
Revenue cool and um I'm also uh I'm also
a music teacher as well uh teaching
course and general music and I do
private lessons on the sides okay aside
for a piano and drums and uh yeah it all
worked out really well for me last year
I'm also a student debt free as of
discount April excellent so uh yeah yeah
so uh having the new income coming with
my most recent teaching job really
helped out tremendously with that that's
cool as of now yeah as of now I have 42
000 uh saved up and I'm hoping by the
end of this year I could get past 80
000. okay is that and that's the goal
eighty thousand dollars saved
yeah at least and that's going to be
your down payment on I'm guessing
an apartment or what are you looking for
what are you looking for
I mean either house or condo I don't
know if I'm just gonna be comfortable
paying what like two grand or more in
rent and just having that are you
looking to live are you looking to live
in the city or are you looking in the
outskirts
uh no uh Long Island okay okay so if you
moved out today what would your rent be
um he rented somewhere
yeah if I rent it somewhere I mean
probably around where I live I mean
we'll probably be north of two grand
which I would definitely not be able to
swing now what's your take-home pay
uh take-home pay I guess each month is
probably gonna be around uh six grand
okay so if you could find something
that's could you find something for 1500
uh I mean it might be a bit of a stretch
I mean especially around here I mean
Long Island in particular
um but I mean I could start looking and
to see what comes up
I would start looking I think you know I
know that you want to get to 80k but
that sounds like it could take take a
stretch of time and I'd like for you to
make that timeline a little bit uh
Slimmer to get out of your parents house
I mean you're making 6K a month I don't
think there's any reason that you can't
support yourself and live on your own
um and if you stayed I would have clear
communication with parents going hey
here's my goal 12 months from now I'm
moving out my goal is to save this much
even if I have don't have all that saved
I'm moving out even if it means renting
somewhere because I think it'll give you
a lot of dignity and Independence that
you don't currently have and I know it's
a high cost of living area I mean it's
an insane situation over there I'm from
Boston so I totally get it that it's
it's a lot of money you need to save up
for that down payment and you looked at
condos in the area and see to see what
that's going to cost you to buy
yeah I just started looking at those I
mean if I'm looking let's say
we're between 300 500 Grand I mean
that's obviously very steep yeah but um
but yeah I've only recently just started
looking at that I haven't really like
tailored my searches on on the condos
lately yeah I'd start looking into that
and also you know how many hours I know
that you're kind of freelancing right
now you're into music how many hours a
week are you working is there a way that
you can pick up more lessons pick up
more you know teaching and and really
amp up your income even more so that you
can make this happen faster even
increase your hourly rate Yeah by a few
bucks
yeah I mean currently it's it's funny I
mean I'm at probably the busiest I've
ever been I have probably 30 students on
the side freelance but uh but my main
job is teaching in a public school so
that's already five days a week okay so
I've got all those going at the same
time I'm working six days a week what is
the public school job pay
so that's around uh 67 000 per year okay
and my pride my private lessons account
for between
and that's an additional 20 to 25 Grand
a year that's good can I just ask you
how much are you charging hourly for
your lessons
so hourly it's around well it's it's
split it by half hour and I teach at two
different places where it's um
um like from 15 or so per half hour so
we're a little over 30 an hour I can't
feel super cheap super cheap can I just
say this and can you teach me Paul oh my
goodness gracious I did lessons Paul I
did lessons for years my husband did
base lessons and keys lessons and I
taught piano and voice lessons and I
only did hour blocks and I charged a
dollar a minute so it was at least sixty
dollars and then after I had a certain
block of students which you have more
than I had I charged a hundred dollars
an hour
and if you're teaching music and you
know how to play music you know your
stuff you need to charge more money dude
tell me about this if you raised your
rates to 30 for a half hour you could do
half the work for the same amount of
money yeah
and no one knows exactly yeah the only
problem is it's within two places like
two separate businesses I'm not teaching
private lessons on my own anymore uh I
man I think that you can Paul I think
there's major opportunity here and
here's the thing I think that when you
get out of your parents house there is a
certain level of comfort and security
when you know you gotta play you know
you know you've got that place right you
know Mom and Dad I can just pull in the
driveway and it's there but when you
start having your own place and you got
to hit that rent I think that that is
going to motivate you in ways that you
never you're going to become so more
much more Innovative because necessity
is the mother of invention when you need
to get that money you need to make that
money you will start having ideas and
you will start making those ideas happen
because you have no choice but to make
those ideas happen so I think Paul for
you for your music business for your
lessons to take off I actually think
that getting out of your parents house
is going to be essential for you and I
hope that you make that move sooner than
later absolutely I love I mean apologies
like a likable guy yeah you're just
rooting for Pauline he's the main
character and we want to see Paul and uh
by the way I want to see him raise his
prices George yes and this is a great
reminder that you don't get a pass on
math because you live in a high cost of
living area true that and so if you want
to live in New York City Long Island
Boston La you name it you gotta make
more in order to still hit your money
goals or you got to show up there when
you and with a whole bunch of money
which most people don't have yep yeah
look at the numbers here you know
getting a condo even for 300 Grand with
80 down that's still 20 200 bucks a
month almost yeah on that 15 year which
is the only mortgage we'd ever recommend
you have because the goal is to get out
of debt not be in it twice as long and
he might have to rent and that's all
right
and keep saving do the side hustle for
one more year save up another 20 use all
the side hustle money yes in a savings
get to a hundred grand as a down payment
yes and I bet you this when Paul gets
out of Mama and poppers or a house he
might meet himself a nice fine lady oh
you know what I'm saying that he I'm
just guessing I'm just guessing here
George because there's something to that
dual income like while marriage is great
dual income is also something that not a
lot of people talk about that's right
having the power of two incomes at your
disposal changes the game it changes
your money goals and we've seen the
numbers married couples just build
wealth quicker because you've got more
manpower they build wealth quicker and
it says that if they combine their
finances they are actually happier
they're more likely to stay together and
they build wealth four times faster
there you go if that's not a reason to
get married I don't know what is
marriage marriage has got a bad rap in
today's culture it has looked at very
negatively especially from the men
they're like well she's just going to
take me to the cleaners I'm like well no
wonder you're still single dude no one
wants to marry that guy with that
attitude yeah I'm con I I have to say
I'm honestly confused by that because I
have seen that when you are in a loving
relationship no addiction nothing crazy
going on right so there's no reason to
not combine the finances but when you do
combine them and you get out of debt
faster you build that wealth faster
it's a win-win amen